for centuries humans have created maps
to help us understand our world and to
ultimately serve as guides
imagine what would be possible by having
a map that could dynamically and with
great accuracy show you how the earth
has changed week over week month over
month year over year
we could get a bird's eye view of the
impact of different resources such as
food and fresh water management wildlife
and ecosystems conservation
sustainable urban development
climate change
public health etc
such an amazing data project is here and
is called dynamic world it offers a free
daily data set that is updated every 14
seconds for anyone to build applications
with the intention of deriving
ecological insights from it
what's even more interesting is that
because you can access mapping data of
all the different surfaces on the earth
called land cover maps as daily data
sets rather than the traditional annual
summary on a static map
it helps unlock greater flexibility for
investigation
this global and high resolution land
cover data set has an amazing
granularity of 10 meters per pixel
and the geospatial data that google
earth engine uses to deliver this
service originates from the european
space agency satellite called sentinel-2
from the eu-copernicus mission which
takes an image of the entire earth
roughly every 5-10 days since mid-2015
dynamic world uses ai to classify these
images of the planet into different land
categories automatically by leveraging
cloud computing we accelerate the
process of labeling what's on the land
which up to very recently took years to
analyze but today can be accessed in
hours or seconds making it a powerful
sustainability platform for everyone
dynamic world was built by my peers in
geo for everyone in collaboration with
the world resource institute society
it can help with things like quantifying
losses from a wildfire
this is an example of the 300 000 acres
of beautiful trees from a city in
california called chico in just a few
days after being impacted by a wildfire
and on a global scale we can quantify
forest and ecosystem loss due to changes
in the way land is used from human
activity such as agriculture and animal
farming
this sector for example is estimated to
produce more than 12 percent of the
carbon pollution globally
but by better understanding its
interdependent effects on habitats we
can remediate with regenerative
solutions
companies interested in having more
regenerative supply chains can use
dynamic world as unilever is presently
doing so in order to help them locate
deforestation due to palm oil
plantations
and so in inspiration of this project we
dedicate this episode to sharing how to
get started with training a model that
helps label satellite pictures into
different land surface classifications
to understand how we are changing the
earth
[Music]
meet tanya she works on google's geo for
everyone team focused on apps for nature
and conservation yeah so one of the
challenges of producing land cover data
sets are that they're incredibly tedious
and manual and require a lot of human
expertise to produce you need to have
experts that understand very specific
biomes very specific ecoregions and know
what's on the ground at that at that
place a lot of these training data sets
are um laborious to produce and take a
lot of
expertise for modern machine learning
approaches you still need a ton of
training data we really hope that people
are going to take dynamic world data and
produce um derivative data sets like
different plantations different crop
types
so we can better understand things like
supply chain traceability as well as
governments who are really struggling to
meet and trying and you know working
hard to meet the pledges that they're
making at uh at climate agreements or
climate conferences and biodiversity
conferences they need tools to be able
to track and measure their progress
towards those agreements that they've
set
you can learn more about how to access
dynamic world in our video's description
or you can load it as an image
collection in earth engines editor
you can also visit their beautiful web
app that demonstrates the art of the
possible where you can choose a date
range
pick a point to analyze the model's
confidence level of land surface via a
chart
and toggle different map layers such as
satellite or google maps view
a big shout out to the brilliant minds
behind this project including googler
chris brown for all his ai contributions
my peers and i in developer relations
were inspired to explore how to approach
this problem of automating land cover
maps by building a geospatial
multi-class classification model which
is a fancy way of saying a model that
classifies many different things from
satellite imagery and so let's dive in
here is a bird's eye view of the
architectural diagram
so for starters we authenticate into an
existing google cloud project or create
a new one via a free trial we will also
need a google earth engine account which
is free
next we identify a data set with labeled
classifications and so we used earth
engines catalog and picked a data set
called european space agency world cover
make a note we could use multiple data
sets if you wanted to combine elevation
data for example but for simplicity we
only used one dataset
next we need to understand the shape of
our inputs and outputs which has three
dimensions width height and number of
bands
in this case these bands correspond to
measurements from sensors of that lovely
rainbow electromagnetic spectrum from
the satellite and can collect values
such as infrared data to water vapor for
example
the outputs are the probability of a
classification of each pixel and since
we have nine classification types we
then have nine values and each value is
the probability of being a type of
surface on the earth
we then typically take the highest
probability as the final label
now i glossed over this matter now but i
cover how this problem is similar to
image classification in our prior
episode on carbon pollution monitoring
if you feel inspired to check it out
next we use the earth engine apis
function to create a balanced data set
and make sure the data set is shuffled
in a random order we do this to minimize
bias in our
model next we choose how much of this
data will go to building a training and
validation data sets and decided they
would respectively have an 80 20 ratio
and we ensure that no data point is
shared in both data sets
we now wait for some time for earth
engine to export both of these data sets
into a data processing format called tf
records into our google cloud storage
bucket
this is a file format optimized for
tensorflow which is an ml library
and now it's time to train a model with
tensorflow we read the training and
validation data sets that earth engine
created
with the trading datasets specifically
we define the model in python with
tensorflow keras which is a high-level
api or interface to tensorflow and use
the validation data set to check the
predictions on data it has never seen
before
we train the model in vertex ai which
then saves it into cloud storage
next we host the model on google cloud
run which functions as a prediction
service
you can then create a visual interface
over it in this case we use numpy and
matplotlib in collab to see a per year
snapshot visualization and an animated
gif
so what's next
if you would like to review this process
in greater detail in the description
below i've included the link to an
interactive notebook with all the code
used to build the sample written by
david cavazos who has co-created this
series with me
you can also find a blog post and
several helpful resources
and community i'm going to leave you
with a lovely fun fact tanya shared
before we end and as a friendly reminder
if you found this content helpful you
can subscribe or leave a comment friends
cheers
everywhere i go now in my head i
classify the land cover i'll be driving
down the street and i'll be like
that's grass or that's why you know
that's trees or what would we classify
that as you know you think about like 10
meter by 10 meter pixels covering the
globe and what do each of those pixels
get classified as right it's super dorky
but
i guess that's true and personal
[Music]
you